- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the Homeroom livestream.
We're very excited to have a conversation
with U.S. Secretary of
Education Miguel Cardona today.
But before we jump into that conversation,
I will remind you a few
of my typical reminders.
First of all, Khan Academy is
a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist through donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please go to khanacademy.org/donate.
I also wanna make a special shout out
to several organizations
that have stepped up
especially during the pandemic.
Many of y'all know that our
traffic tripled a year ago
when we went into the pandemic.
A lot of more folks
have been leaning on us.
Our server costs went up.
And so, special thanks
to Bank of America, AT&T,
Google.org, Novartis,
Fastly, and General Motors,
and many other supporters of Khan Academy
for stepping up and making
sure that we're in a position
to support millions, tens
of millions of learners
around the world.
So thank you for that.
And I also wanna remind
folks that there is a version
of this livestream in podcast form
wherever you get your podcasts,
Homeroom with Sal, the Podcast.
So please check that out.
So with that, I am very excited
to introduce Dr. Miguel Cardona,
U.S. Secretary of Education.
Secretary Cardona, thank
you for joining us.
- Hey, happy to be here in Homeroom.
Happy to be here.
- So maybe a great place
for folks to start,
I think people know
Secretary of Education,
federal government,
it's the most senior education
leader in the country.
But from your vantage point,
what do you see as the role,
the job, the potential of
U.S. Secretary of Education?
- You know, supporting kids,
supporting students from pre-K
to higher education really.
It's really making sure,
I'd like to think this role is really,
it really needs to be
the greatest child
advocate in the country,
to make sure that our education program
is meeting the needs
of all of our students,
the diverse needs of our students,
and making sure that
we're letting education
be that great equalizer
that it was for me.
- And how do you view that?
Do you view it as, is it advocacy?
What are the levers at your disposal?
The U.S. famously has a very, you know,
it's a very federated system in education.
A lot of the resources
are happening at the state
and the local government.
Where does your role fit
in in the whole ecosystem?
- Sure.
So, you know, working with states,
working with local districts
to help support them.
Right now as we recover from this pandemic
there is more funding coming
from the federal government.
But, you know, making sure
that we're using this position
to support, to elevate best practices,
to use the position as a bully pulpit
around those things that
we know work for kids
and those things that we
should be doing in education,
but also at the policy level too
making sure that we're advocating
and also protecting
the rights of students.
They deserve a free and
appropriate public education
throughout our country.
- And I definitely wanna get into
some of those policy questions.
And I think it's an exciting time
to be in education generally.
I'm imagining a very exciting time
to be Secretary of Education.
There's so much to do.
There's never been more energy,
I think, behind education,
potentially more funding behind education
is what we're starting to see.
But before we jump into
that, I wanna remind everyone
you can ask your questions
on YouTube and Facebook.
I'll try to surface as many
of the questions as we can
to Secretary Cardona.
But I'd like to know a little
bit about your life journey.
I don't think a lot of
kids wake up in the morning
when they're seven years old and say,
"I will be U.S. Secretary
of Education in 2021."
So what was that pathway?
What got you here?
- Listen, I grew up.
My parents came from Puerto Rico
when they were in their
teens and, you know,
my grandparents moved for a better life.
My grandfather cut sugar
cane in Puerto Rico.
And, you know, the money was
paying a little bit better
in Hartford, Connecticut,
where you cut tobacco.
So he settled in Meriden.
He left the beautiful
paradise island over there,
palm trees and beaches, to
go live on the fourth floor
of apartment projects in a place where
he didn't know the language,
didn't know the culture.
But he did that so that he
could provide for his family.
My parents were born.
They lived in that same community.
And early on, Sal,
I was modeled service to community.
And the schools gave me so much,
so I ended up becoming an educator.
But service to the community
was really what I wanted
to do for my life.
And it took me from a classroom teacher,
fourth grade teacher, to
Secretary of Education.
But at the end of the
day, it's still service.
- And fill in the blanks a little bit.
'Cause you said, you know,
service, classroom teacher,
Secretary of Education.
But how does that happen?
You know, did you go into administration?
What was that journey like?
- I went to a technical high school
because, you know, we had
a big family in Meriden.
And my eldest cousin went
to a technical high school,
so all the little cousins
followed, you know,
like little ducks crossing the road.
And it was a great experience.
I learned automotive
technology for four years.
And I had a teacher that
said, "You know, Miguel,
"you should consider teaching."
So I wanted to go become an art teacher.
And I went to college thinking
I was gonna become an art teacher.
I loved the arts.
And again, teaching is an
extension of service, right?
So I went into college,
but I gravitated toward
elementary education.
I became a fourth grade teacher.
I loved that role.
I never wanted to leave the classroom.
But I got asked and
pushed into administration
by the superintendent at the time.
Then I became an elementary
school principal for 10 years,
loved that role, really
engaged with families.
I served students with disabilities.
I served students that
were learning English
as a second language.
We had children with developmental delays.
We had children with multiple handicaps.
It was a really wonderful
learning experience for me.
I became an assistant
superintendent in that district.
I did a little work teaching
at the college level.
And then, the governor
of Connecticut called
for me to serve as
Commissioner of Education.
And I enjoyed that role.
I'm really passionate about addressing
inequities in education.
And then the pandemic hit.
And, you know, we worked really hard
to try to safely reopen
schools in Connecticut.
And that work and that passion
got me a call from the
president of the United States.
So now, I'm fortunate to be serving
as Secretary of Education.
- You know, I definitely wanna get into
what you hope to do in this role now
and some of the policy questions.
But I wanna double click again on this.
Just talking to you, I can
sense some of your energy
and the passion for what you
do, so it's not surprising.
But what do you think it was?
You know, what do you think
it was about that teacher
that said that maybe you
should become a teacher?
What did they see in you?
And then, what do you think
other folks have seen in you
or you saw in yourself
that allowed you to go
on this very, very impressive journey?
- You know, what's special about me
is that there's nothing special about me,
that I represent every
student in the classroom
that, you know, just wants to
do well and wants to serve.
And I had a teacher just realize
that I was using my artwork
to communicate my values.
So there was a mural that I did, Sal.
Back then, you know, it was
like late 80s, early 90s.
And I did a mural that said,
"There's only one race, the human race."
And I had in that mural all
these different characters
from different backgrounds
and different cultural
traditions, different dress.
And the teacher said, "You know,
"why don't you make that
a mural in the cafeteria?"
So she saw that I was using my art
to communicate my values.
So she gave me that opportunity
and that really made me feel
like: Well, I can do this.
And it's important to
name those folks by name.
So Linda Ransom was that
teacher who saw that in me
and said, "Why don't you
consider a career in education?"
And that's what did it.
So it was really a teacher
seeing something in me
that I can communicate through arts.
And that's all it took.
And I was hooked after that.
- I'm so glad you
highlighted it in that way.
Because it's very easy to say:
What does the governor see in you?
Or what did a school leader see in you?
But you're so right.
It's those teachers early on in your life
that when you might, you know, for me
and you're right, it's
important to name them.
Octavio Hernandez, my algebra teacher,
and he was our mentor for the Math Club.
I was a little bit of a math nerd.
- (laughs) Just a little, right.
- And Dr. Santanilla who
was a professor at UNO.
And I didn't have a computer at home,
and he let me use his
computers while I was doing
some dual enrollment
things in high school.
So you're absolutely right.
It's those teachers that make
all the difference in the world.
And all sorts of questions are coming in.
So I wanna make sure I have time
to get to all these questions.
But, you know, now that
you are in this role
and it's still the first few
months of your tenure here,
what are your hopes and fears?
What are you hoping?
And, you know, if we look
back on this in 10 years,
it's like: Yes, we were
able to do X, Y, and Z.
And what are your fears on top of that?
- You know, 59 days to be exact.
But we hit the ground running
and we're gonna continue running.
I know that there's a finite window
to serve as Secretary of
Education and there's such need.
Since we've been collecting data,
there have been gaps in
outcomes for students.
And we have to make sure that
we're gonna address that.
I don't think there's ever been a time
in the history of our education system
where we've been as close to
a reset button as we are now.
So yes, the pandemic really
did a number on our country
and it's gonna take time
to reel in from that.
But I wanna seize this
opportunity to rethink
some of those things that we've been doing
that are maybe not best for kids,
or maybe really just re-imagine
how we can reopen our doors
not only physically and
make sure the lights are on
but just rethink how we're
educating our students
and how we're partnering with families
and how we're listening to students
in this process of
reopening and recovering.
- Are there certain areas
that you are particularly excited about?
You're right, you know, with
the pandemic, and education,
I've been in this game
for a little while as well
and I've never seen so much
energy behind education
because it's a bit of a reboot, reset
because of the pandemic.
But where do you see as the opportunities
and where do you see
as the risks right now?
- Sure.
So tremendous opportunities.
You know, I'm talking to an
innovative genius here, right?
I remember hearing your
name in a cafeteria
at Hanover School over 10, 12 years ago
where a teacher said, "Hey,
check out these videos."
And look at now.
You know, my kids,
Khan Academy is a topic
at the dinner table
at most houses where
I've been an educator.
So how do we allow
innovation to really drive
where we're going?
How do we kind of, you
know, revisit those things
that are sacred cows that maybe are not
in the best interest of students?
So when we're looking
at time, time in seats,
how we utilize technology,
how we use blended learning.
You know, blended learning is something
that happened overnight, and
we're just getting better.
How we're closing the digital divide
to make sure we have
greater access to learning
so that I'm not limited to the experiences
that I have in my community
or in my schoolhouse.
You know, those are some
areas of innovation.
We can have students
connecting with students
across the country, just
like I'm connecting with you.
Some of the fears, some of the fears.
So while we're pleased
to see that about 80%
of the pre-K-eight schools have some form
of in-person learning at this point,
we know that the data is
disproportionate by race.
We know that Black and Brown
students and Asian students
are less likely to go into school
even if that option is there.
So what we've seen
happen in this past year
is a gross exacerbation of opportunities
and outcomes for our students
based on not only race
but also where they live, right?
So rural communities have
been impacted significantly
based on the fact that
the internet connection
maybe isn't as strong.
So we have a lot of work to do there.
And my fear is that we don't
maintain the level of urgency
that we need to really
reshape where we're going.
That would be my greatest fear
that our urgency dissipates over time.
- Yeah, no, completely
understand that last notion.
You know, there's a group of,
just through the work
we do at Khan Academy,
of superintendents and
state commissioners,
your old job,
that we've connected with.
And I even get 'em together on
a Zoom every other Friday now
to discuss some of these topics.
And they're all feeling
exactly what you're feeling.
This is an unusual moment.
The pandemic has been incredibly hard,
especially on some of the communities
that, frankly, already
needed some extra support
because of various contexts pre-pandemic.
And now, there's a unique opportunity
to hopefully solve the problems
that the pandemic introduced,
but also move ahead.
And there's incredible
federal dollars coming way.
There's the third round of
stimulus had a lot of dollars
that are coming from
the federal government.
And I know y'all are proposing
more that I wanna talk about.
Where do you see, have you seen examples?
Are there things in the
back of y'all's mind
that you see it like:
That's going to be a really
good use of these funds.
I think it averages $800 or
$900 per student in America.
And in certain areas,
it might be as much as $2,000 or $3,000.
So it's significant resources
for the next three years.
- You know, I have to start
with social emotional
well-being of students.
What I'm finding is that
we are still in the middle of a pandemic.
And we can't think that just
because the lights are on
and the hallways are clean
and the doorknobs have been wiped down
that we can go back to business as usual.
Many of our students have
experienced a lot of loss
whether it's loss of loved
ones or, you know, loss of jobs
or their parents being underemployed now
or having to change and
not seeing loved ones
for a long period of time.
So we have to make sure
that when we reopen schools,
we're ready and prepared to
meet our students where they are
and provide them that
support that they need
to be emotionally safe
so that bandwidth for learning can grow.
So that's one of the areas
where I see that that's working.
Another area that I'm noticing
with the Help is Here tour
is that in those places
where there's intentional
collaboration, right,
so collaboration that's deeper
than it was prior to the pandemic,
those are the places that
are reopening quicker
and more safe, and allowing for innovation
to take root earlier.
So it's really some of those
underlying things like that,
social emotional
well-being of our students,
of our educators, but also
making sure that we reorganize
so that we're more responsive
to the needs of the community.
That's how we're gonna
get students back in.
And that's how we're gonna
get families to re-engage.
So funds for educators to
help lower class sizes,
especially for those students
that were hit hardest
by the pandemic and maybe haven't been
in a school house for over a year,
more social workers,
more school counselors,
better tools for teachers,
better training for teachers.
You know, we keep asking teachers
to do more and more and more.
We need to make sure we embed
professional learning opportunities,
in a creative way too.
It can't be just packing
more into those three PD days
that they get.
So we really need to rethink those things.
But those states that are using the funds
to provide social emotional support,
good afterschool programming
that are hands-on,
good summer learning opportunities
for students to get out into the community
and do camp-like activities
and learn with their hands
and discovery learning,
those are the places
that are finding the most
success with reopening.
But those are the ones that are
really utilizing their funds
to address the needs of the students.
- You know, I love that answer
because I think in education,
because the things we measure are often
things like test scores
in reading or math,
we can become very
obsessed with test scores.
And it is, at least in
my opinion, important
to measure these things to
understand where you are.
But when we face a situation like this,
it's very tempting to immediately get into
how do we get back, fill in the gaps,
fill in the academic gaps.
But to your point, and
I've seen this as a father
and we've seen this in
the work at Khan Academy,
if you don't have, if the kids aren't
in the right place from a
social emotional point of view,
if there isn't the right
collaboration amongst the adults,
there's not the right
training amongst the adults,
it doesn't matter what tools you provide.
It doesn't matter what
curricula you provide.
You're not going to get the same outcomes.
And the other way around,
if you do have good social emotional,
if you do have good collaboration,
it also does not matter what
kind of curricula you have.
You'll probably have a good outcome.
So I think that's a very powerful notion.
- Absolutely.
We have to start with
where the students are,
where the children are.
You know, someone once told me
when I was student teaching,
she was a teacher for
students with disabilities.
She said, "Miguel, don't forget.
"You teach children, not curriculum.
"You teach kids, not curriculum."
And that stuck with me.
We need to start with
where the students are.
And right now, they need to
feel a safe school environment.
They need to have the
relationship, that R,
before the reading, writing, arithmetic.
I think it can be done together.
But we cannot skip past that
social emotional well-being
of our students, but also our staff.
- That makes a ton of sense.
And then, one extra layer, as you know,
for Khan Academy to do its work,
there needs to be some level
of connectivity devices.
Obviously, it's not just Khan Academy.
It opens up a whole new world.
There's another not-for-profit effort
spawned in reaction to the pandemic
around free tutoring
called schoolhouse.world.
Once again, kids are not going to be able
to access things like this
unless they have access.
How are you thinking
about the digital divide?
I know the American Rescue Package
had several billions of dollars for it.
How confident are you that
we're gonna crack that nut?
- I'm very, I'm very confident.
Listen, the digital
divide should be a thing
that's in our rear view mirror soon.
Yes, it's gonna take bold actions,
but the bold funding is there
and the direction is there,
and the guidance is that we
have a president that gets it.
So let's go.
Let's close the digital divide.
We all know the laptop is the new pencil.
So let's move forward and let's
open the doors for students.
That's a basic level of equity
that we need to provide.
I know states and communities
are thinking about it.
That thinking has been
accelerated with the pandemic.
The tools are there;
the resources are there.
Let's just get it done.
And let's talk about quality instruction
and recognizing that
that's a tool to get to good
educational opportunity.
So I really feel strongly.
In Connecticut, one of the things we did
is we prioritized with
the governor's leadership
and the State Department
of Education's leadership.
We prioritized closing that digital divide
because we know that it's not only about
getting the computer up
and the internet access.
It's also about getting quality content
on the other side of that screen.
And that's critically important.
That's how gaps are exacerbated,
when we don't have quality content.
So the first step is getting
a device, good connectivity,
and then quality content.
Those three things are important.
- It makes a ton of sense.
And I wanna get to everyone's questions,
but I have so many myself.
So I'm going to indulge myself.
You know, y'all,
I've actually never
seen any administration,
and I think the pandemic is part of it,
but I've never seen anyone
with as bold tangible plans
around education as we're starting to see.
On the American Families
Plan, and I'm reading this,
you know, $200 billion for
free universal preschool,
$109 billion for free community college,
$80 billion for Pell grants.
And that's not the complete list.
But that's a lot of dollars.
You know, $200 billion for
free universal preschool
for three and four-year olds.
I think there's about 10 or 11 million
three and four-year olds in the country.
So that comes out to, if
I'm doing the math right,
something like $20,000 per
student to give them that pre-K.
And as a father of young children,
I appreciate more than anyone
how much that creates an
advantage or support for kids.
We've invested in it at Khan Academy Kids.
But how hopeful are you that
these things are going to pass?
And then how do you see
them getting implemented?
Because there are obviously
a lot of preschools,
but we don't have a public
preschool infrastructure.
How do you see that money flowing down?
- So, you know, first and foremost,
those are technical
strategies that are being
recommended by the president
who gets what we need to do,
who gets that education is the
foundation of this country,
that education is the best economic driver
not only for our country,
but for these individuals.
We know that students are
more likely to graduate
if they have pre-K experiences,
more likely to take higher
level courses, honors courses.
We know that college graduates,
community college graduates
boost their earning potential by 21%.
Everyone wins here.
So we have a president that gets it.
The funds are aimed at providing
an additional four years
of school for the students
to give them a leg up.
As he said last night, you know,
we are competing with the world.
And he gets that we have to be bold,
to invest in our students.
I mean, where better can we invest, right,
in our children across
the country to make sure
that they have the
opportunity to succeed in life
and that our country can continue to grow.
I am confident that there's
gonna be support behind this.
And I do believe that you're right,
the implementation matters.
But educators have shown this past year
that they could rise to the challenge
and that they're prepared
to put the students first
when making decisions.
And we need to act with
the same level of urgency
that our president has
toward supporting children.
And we're gonna get it done.
We're going to get it done.
- Yeah, no, absolutely.
It's very inspiring.
I have a bunch of questions coming in.
These are actually from
two colleagues of mine.
One is Nick Breen on Facebook says,
"Will the two years of
free community college
"aspect of the plan be available
to all fields of study?"
And Kristen DiCerbo,
who is actually Khan Academy's
Chief Learning Officer,
is asking, "We continue to see students
"entering community colleges
without the reading, writing,
"and math skills they
need to be successful.
"Often, these students get stuck
"in developmental math programs.
"How do we support these?"
So I kind of view those as
two sides of the same coin.
- Fantastic questions.
And I think, you know,
they do connect, right?
So we know that our students
that when they go to college
and they're still not
reading at grade level,
there's work that has to
be done at the K-12 level.
So I'm really hopeful that the Rescue Plan
and the CARES Plan really
and then the budget that the
president is putting forward
supports strong K-12, pre-K-12 learning
and high standards for all
students across the country
so we don't have that issue.
And then, the community college connection
to the high schools,
we have to make sure that those programs,
while the details of what programs
would be accepted under that,
what I wanna see, Sal,
is a better connection
between our high school,
actually our middle school, high school,
and two year colleges so
that we provide students
with viable pathways into the workforce
in careers that exist now,
careers that will exist
five years from now
so that these students can take
advantage of those two years
and really go into the workforce
or continue to a four-year program
and continue to get their education.
Those connections between
the community college
and our middle and high schools
is one of the goals for me.
There has to be a more clear throughlines
so more students take advantage of it
and they lead to careers
that these students wanna do
that are needed now.
- I couldn't agree more.
You know, one of the
questions that I always wonder
and this goes off of
Kristen's question is,
you know the stats.
Right now, 65%, 70% of all kids
who show up at community college,
they don't even place
into college algebra.
They place into remedial math
which is essentially pre-algebra
at sixth or seventh grade mathematics.
And we also know that college algebra,
one, when you don't place into it,
it's a huge signal that
you're not gonna graduate
and you're gonna have debt,
and that college algebra itself
is a huge gating factor for
a lot of kids, even though
it really should have been
taught in ninth or 10th grade.
Algebra one and algebra two
are essentially college algebra.
And I love your advice,
that Khan Academy and this
free tutoring platform,
schoolhouse.world we're creating,
how it can help teachers and students get
maybe ways we can
partner with universities
to get college algebra credit
before they even leave high school.
Are you thinking things like that
so that college algebra
should just be off the table,
so it shouldn't be a
gating factor anymore?
- You know, one of the things
we learned in this pandemic
is we have to think outside the box.
So we need to really make sure that we're
providing opportunities for
students to learn these things.
And it doesn't have to be
during the regular school day.
It could be, we could be creative.
But I wanna take it back
a little bit further.
They're not accessing those classes,
they're not passing those
classes in eighth or ninth grade
because maybe in third grade,
they were at a first-grade reading level.
And maybe in first grade,
they were still learning their letters.
So this universal pre-kindergarten
and early childhood focus
that the president is providing here
will help alleviate some
of those issues as well.
So yes, we have to get
creative for those students
that are underserved and
that we haven't gotten
to that point where they're
passing those courses.
But when we have a strong foundation
in early childhood
education, it's less likely
that that pattern is gonna continue.
So I'm really pleased with that
focus from President Biden.
And I know that if implemented well,
those issues are gonna start going away
because we're gonna better
prepare our students early.
And the gaps that we see
when our three and four
and five-year-olds come in
are gonna be diminished
when we have strong programs
at the early childhood level.
It's all connected.
- And I think I could
predict what you might say,
but what's your view on
the student debt crisis?
I didn't see that.
I mean, it's implicitly
addressed in some of the things
like free community college
and more Pell grants.
But we know it's over a
trillion dollars of debt.
I have even people in my
family who are in their 40s
who are still paying off debt
or maybe even in some cases given up.
What can we do there that can
help unlock a lot of folks?
- That's a major issue.
And you know, it's a two-pronged approach.
The first prong is making
sure we can do what we can
to support students that are in debt now.
We're having conversations
about what that might look like.
But the second step to that
I don't think gets discussed as much
but we really need to focus on
is ensuring that this
doesn't happen again,
that we have public
service loan forgiveness
that actually works.
You know, we've had a system that rejects
like 98% of the applicants.
That's unacceptable.
We have to do borrower defense better.
We have to make sure that our colleges
are providing a good return on investment
for these learners that are coming in,
especially these first gen students.
You know, I read a fact recently that
some borrowers are in
greater debt 12 years later
because they were never able
to knock down the principal.
So we have to fix that.
We have to make sure we
have pathways to college
that are affordable so more
students take advantage of that.
So it's a two-pronged approach.
Yes, we're gonna look at
potential loan forgiveness conversation
and making sure that
we're supporting those
who are in major debt.
But we're also gonna make sure
that we're stopping the bleeding
by promoting good practices
that alleviate some of
this debt accumulation
that we see in our students.
- Yeah, and it seems like
even our bankruptcy laws
are a little bit strange.
It's easier to cancel your debt
when you max out a credit card
or you run a business into the ground
than, you know, if
you're not able to cover
all of your student debt.
There should be a penalty,
which is bankruptcy or
your credit score gets,
but at least there's a way.
That's why bankruptcy exists, to reboot.
- I'm excited about bringing folks onboard
that have a student-centered approach
to the policies that we're making
and ensuring that we're
not in this position again
in five years.
Absolutely, I'm looking
forward to having more
work done on this issue.
- No, I mean, it's very
inspiring to hear that.
You know, I know we're almost out of time.
You're super busy.
First of all, let me just say
I consider what we're
doing at Khan Academy,
what we're trying to do
at schoolhouse.world,
these are in service
to hopefully the same mission and vision.
So, you know, consider us at your service
of how we can move the dial
for learners and teachers
and parents in America.
But I'd love to, you know,
for you to finish up with
any messages you have.
We have a lot of teachers,
a lot of parents,
a lot of children watching right now.
- Thank you very much.
And thanks for the invite.
It was nice to be, this
was a long Homeroom.
Usually, Homeroom is about 10 minutes.
So this is nice that we
had a 30-minute Homeroom.
But my message is, first
of all, thank you, Sal,
for everything that
you've done in education
in supporting educators,
supporting students across the country.
Really appreciate it.
My own children, I have a
14-year old and a 16-year old
who benefit from Khan Academy.
And I just wanna say thank
you for what you've done.
But to the educators and the families,
I wanna say thank you for what
you've done this past year.
But know we have an opportunity
to hit the reset button
and really elevate our practices
in making sure that we're
supporting our educators,
supporting our students in different ways
so that all students have
access to a quality education.
And we're gonna do it together.
One thing that I learned,
that intentional collaboration
is how we're gonna move
ahead as a country.
So I look forward to
working with you, Sal,
with the families, with
educators to make sure
we can do the very best
for all of the students
across the country.
Again, thanks for letting me be on.
- Well, Secretary Cardona,
this was a real honor.
And I'll say it again, your energy,
you know, you're you're only 59 days in
but your energy and your
background and your experience
gives me very high hopes
for what we're as a country
going to be able to accomplish together.
So thank you so much
for your service here.
- All right, take care.
- Well, thanks everyone for joining.
Hopefully, you enjoyed that
conversation as much as I did.
As I always say, these
conversations go far faster than,
(laughs) time flies
when you're having fun.
I wish we could have spoken
for another few hours.
But I have hopes.
You know, I've never seen more energy
at the federal level behind education.
Part of it's from the pandemic.
Part of it is,
it feels like just where
the headspace is right now.
And, you know, I think
there is an opportunity
that all collectively that we can imagine
a really exciting world together.
So thanks everyone for joining.
And I look forward to seeing
you in future Homerooms.